Das ist wirklich ein bisschen paradox professor kommunen wasser von der harvard university meint dass unser universum vielleicht gar nicht
existieren könnte und wasser einer der führenden vertreter der stringtheorie meint mit diesem ansatz indizien für die theorie finden zu können
das wäre der absolute durchbruch und würde unser verständnis von raum und zeit und sechs bis sieben weiteren dimensionen
grundlegend verändern what klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
Würden belege für die stringtheorie gefunden werden dann käme das einer kompletten änderung unseres weltbildes gleichen diese unbewiesene hypothese besagt
dass nicht teilchen die kleinsten einheiten in unserem universum sind sondern strings viel kleinere fäden die je nachdem wie sie schwingen
unterschiedliche teilchen erscheinen lassen quax personen oder laptop als
forschungsteams diese fäden allerdings berichteten stießen sie auf etwas unglaubliches dieses existieren nicht in raum und zeit sondern ihn vielmehr
dimensionen nämlich 10 bis 11 aber wo sind diese dimension warum können wir sie nicht erfahren
auch darauf hat diese hypothese eine antwort sie sind auf kleinstem raum
zusammengefaltet quasi
zusammengeknüllt dann durchreichen stellten die forscher und forscherinnen dann fest dass auf dieser grundlage aber und aber
universen existieren könnten und an diesem punkt hat sich
kommunen wasser jetzt festgebissen zahlreiche dieser universen können nämlich gar nicht existieren und unser universum gehört dazu
jedenfalls so wie wir es bisher beschrieben haben in einem existierenden
universum muss zb die gravitation viel schwächer sein als alle anderen kräfte das stimmt hier
gravitationswellen als folge sind nur sehr schwach und kaum zu finden aber eines funktioniert laut seinen berechnungen nicht ein
universum mit 70 prozent dunkler energie wie wir es hier annehmen ein solches universum ist laut bafa
unmöglich dunkle energie ist eine auch erst theoretisch vorhergesagt der energie die dafür verantwortlich ist dass unser universum immer schneller auseinander
driftet werden wir heute noch ganz viele nachbargalaxien sehen können wird das in ferner zukunft nicht mehr der fall sein
sie sind zu weit weg um sie sehen zu können 70 prozent dessen was existiert soll diese
in unserem universum sein doch wasser hat etwas anderes berechnet und das widerspricht wirklich so einigen laut seinen berechnungen für ein
existierendes universum auf basis der stringtheorie darf diese energie
keinen festen wert haben sondern sie muss sich verändern sprich in einem aus unserer sicht geschlossenen systemen in unserem universum
verändert sich sehr der inhalt das ist verrückt verrückt ist für die physik aber auch der wert der dunklen energie nach berechnungen wäre es viel
natürlicher wenn die dunkle energie na ja ungefähr 1000 mal stärker wäre als sie ist aber als
natürlich wurde bisher auch angesehen dass sie einen laut wasser
unmöglichen festen wert hätte also schwamm drüber da scheint einiges nicht zustimmen und da könnte wasser jetzt helfen er hat nämlich ausgerechnet
wie sich die dunkle energie ändern müsste wenn die stringtheorie gelten würde und das ist extrem langsam aber messbar
sprich wenn eine veränderung der dunklen energie gemessen würde dann wäre das ein starkes indiz dafür dass die stringtheorie
tatsächlich gilt das würde wirklich alles auf den kopf stellen am cern müsste dringend ein viel größerer
teilchenbeschleuniger gebaut werden um die strings zu finden und wir würden in einem doch sehr
seltsamen zehn bis elf dimensionalen universum leben im rahmen des dark energy service wird gerade eine dreidimensionale karte der dunklen energie
angefertigt zusätzlich werden sich die weltraumteleskope wie first und glied in zukunft die dunkle energie
genauer anschauen die ergebnisse könnten wirklich revolutionär sein wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann abonniert clixoom
genau glocke nicht vergessen dafür hier klicken volkmer auf whatsapp da gibt es die videos früher dafür hier klicken
keine werbung mehr auf gigs um gibt es wenn ihr mitglied wertet der link ist unter dem video wer nicht mal am computer anschauen
und hier geht es weiter mit das ende des universums bis dann
bleibt dran